TJ Fletcher was a founder and
administrator of Iceberg a website which
sold other fraudsters tools to deceive
and scam thousands of victims in the UK
and across the world
through the website criminals brought
the services provided by Fletcher to
commit fraud on an industrial scale
resulting in total losses of more than
43 million pounds to the victims in the
UK alone
fraud is not a victimless crime and the
cost to the many victims in this case
has not just been Financial it has also
had a huge emotional impact causing
extreme distress and Devastation to
those affected many of whom had their
bank accounts emptied and their life
savings stolen from them this is a
complex and challenging case and I would
like to thank the Metropolitan Police
and the many national and international
law enforcement Partners who worked with
the CPS to secure the evidence for us to
present in court we were able to show
how Fletcher was instrumental in the
setting up of the website and how it
gave people the tools to defraud others
we will continue to work with
investigators to prosecute the Foresters
who use the website and we will be
pursuing confiscation proceedings
against Fletcher to recover the money he
made from this criminality we hope that
this case will encourage all of those
who think that they've been the victim
of the fraud to report it to police or
to action for it every report can help
prevent another person become a victim
and enable us to prosecute offenders
thank you
good afternoon
my name is Helen Rance I'm a detective
superintendent in the Met police leading
the cybercrime unit
today's results and sentence is is the
result of a long and complex
investigation
by creating ice Booth Fletcher enabled a
Gateway for thousands of criminals to
defraud innocent victims out of millions
of pounds
before it was shut down ice Booth was
constantly growing with 700 new users
registering every week and it was
earning 80 000 pounds per week
Fletcher was leading an extravagant
lifestyle benefiting from the prophets
having no care for the misery he was
responsible for
he would often go abroad for long
periods of time and he owned luxury cars
and watches
our wider investigation into the
suspected users of ice Booth continue
in the UK we have now arrested 169
individuals and we're Gathering evidence
against them
work is ongoing to identify many more
this was the UK's largest ever proactive
fraud investigation
I'd like to thank our partners who have
assisted us including the CPS the city
of London Police the National Crime
agency the Cyber defense Alliance
international law enforcement and many
many others
this operation was the first time we
have proactively targeted fraud on such
a large scale
our proactivity to Target cyber-enabled
fraud in this way will continue thank
you